uh sir my name is Gil Roy from Bombay
I'm a
businessman and uh thank you for the
opportunity to speak here I've really
enjoyed today my first
time now many Muslim countries do not
permit conversion out of Islam but
correct me if I'm wrong I don't know of
any non-muslim majority country which
prohibits people from converting into
Islam now what what is the right thing
in Islam because as you say you know you
don't need the sword for Islam and
thousands and millions of followers will
anyway get into Islam what would be your
response the brother asked a very good
question and a very important question
that why don't some of the Muslim
countries allow conversion or allow
propagation they don't allow the
propagation to take place they don't
allow conversion from anyone to convert
Muslim to a non-muslim basic question
whether it be anyone brother as far as
the propagation is concerned there are
countries for example Saudi Arabia which
does not allow propagation the only
country which I know very well which
does not allow
propagation that is Saudi Arabia and the
reason is that suppose brother you want
to start a school
if you want to start a school you are
taking an interview of a match
teacher so when you take the interview
of the match teacher you ask the
question 2 + 2 is equal to how much so
one M teacher says 2 + 2 is equal to 3
the second math teacher says 2 + 2 is
equal to 4 the third math teacher says 2
+ 2 equal to 5 now many people say
what's the problem let them preach any
religion whoever wants to accept let
them accept I will ask you a question
will you allow a math teacher in your
school to teach 2+ 2 is equal to 3 will
you select the math teacher who says 2
plus equal to 5 you say no I know Mats
I'm definite about it in mats 2 + 2 is
equal to 4 and nothing
else so as far as religion is concerned
Saudi Arabia is very confirmed it agrees
with the verse of the Quran in Surah
Imran chapter 3 verse number
19 Islam the only religion acceptable in
the sight of Mighty God is peace
acquired by submitting to almighty God
they will not allow anyone else to
preach anything
wrong but in science and technology they
say to the Americans veran you're most
welcome they get people from England
they get people from India no problem in
science and technology they're not
number one so in science and technology
they have people coming from America
from England from Singapore from
Philippines from India from all over the
world but as far as Dean is concerned
they are sure they 100% sure this
is right same as you are sure that
2 + 2 is equal to 4 you will not allow
any wrong teachings same way I agree
with that I'm a student of compara
religion brother there's no religious
scripture on the face of the earth
besides the Quran which says that this
is the only true religion you read the
scriptures of the Hindus you read the
scripture of the Christians the Bible
nowhere does the bible say that
Christianity is right the word
Christianity doesn't exist in the Bible
do you know that the word word
the word Hindu doesn't exist in The
Vedas do you know that nowhere does the
vas say that this is the only right
religion nowhere does the bible say that
this is the only right religion so Quran
is the only religious scripture on the
face of the Earth where almighty God
says
emphatically Islam the only religion
acceptable in the sight of almighty God
is Islam so as far as preaching
propagating and religion is concerned
I'm sure that if you know what is
confirmed they will not allow anyone
else to preach something which is wrong
this India it's a secular country it's
not a Hindu country it's in the
constitution of the people for the
People by the people I'm an Indian
geographically I'm a Hindu because I'm
an Indian but practicing Muslim I'm a
practicing Muslim it's my Birthright in
this country to preach propagate and
practice this religion that is what is
in the constit tion so you have to
change your
Constitution thank you brother can we
have the next question from the sister
side similarity of Hindu and Muslim
Islam Mar congratulate sister just for
the benefit of those who don't
understand Hindi the sister said that
she had heard my lecture the first time
a few years back in aad midan in Bombay
on the topic similarities between Islam
and Hinduism and since that day she has
been appreciating Islam and today she
has accepted Islam as a lifestyle and we
welcome you to the religion of Peace So
we pray to Allah subhana tala that may
Allah accept and inshallah you get Jenna
get the best of this world and thank you
sister any question yeah uh I was sya
now I'm Zara Bilal Khan I converted to
Islam I want to check one thing that you
were saying like there is no morti and
something like that but there is one
place in Kerala it is like there is one
Statue which is coming from the uh Rock
and it is growing then why is it
so as a question nothing like morti I
said but she knows of a place in Kerala
in which there is a statue in the
mountain or the rock she's saying it is
growing how it is growing the question
that
means there's something in the Statue
sister do you know even mountains grow
do you know that yeah yeah so if you
know that's how the statue can grow that
does not mean that does not mean it has
got life in it no it's coming from uh
like inside the rock there is nothing
statue on the rock it is coming from
inside the rock so that's what I'm
telling you sisters coming from inside
the rock even the mountain can grow
sister how does it grow you know in
geology we study that it can keep on
growing and there are many such examples
for example we know that a few years
back there was a ganes statue which were
drinking milk it's a simple scientific
phenomenon
osmosis it's a simple phenomenon of
Osmosis that if you have a jug with a
sprout and you put on the milk it will
automatically rise it's osmosis that
doesn't mean that the statue is drinking
milk and that's how the many TV channels
exposed so what we have to realize
sister that these are inanimate
objects as the vaa clearly
mentions in yade chapter number 32 verse
number
three of that God there is no pratima
there is no image there is no statue
there is no sculpture there's no
photograph hope to answer the question
but one thing then how was the shape
coming from the inside there is one
shape which is coming outside sister you
know shape as far as shape is concern a
human being can give shape by chisling
automatically naturally it can come
there's no problem there are so many
statements mentioning that there are
trees which are mentioning M or some
trees mentioning laah see all the things
don't carry weight at all we are talking
about truth sister and there are many
mountains which look like human faces
haven't you seen so it is by nature if
it resembles something that doesn't mean
it's a miracle you have to follow the
Hindu scriptures and the Quran and the
Bible which say almighty God has got no
images the stone can look like a man can
look like an image can look like a
statue that doesn't mean it is God's
sister thank you and many of these
stones and IM and Idols if it falls it
breaks when it cannot help itself how
will it help you and me sister hope the
answer the question thank you thank you
sister yes brother the next question
good evening sir my name is subash C I'm
lecturer from chemistry Department Tana
College in the beginning of your lecture
you said that Quran talks about uh
giving peace to humanity I my question
is that if it is talking about peace
then why so many many young men from
various countries are falling to the
prey of terrorism in the name of jihad
what is the concept of
jihad thank you sir the brother asked a
good question that if Islam and Quran
speaks about peace to humanity then how
come there are so many young Muslim and
other Muslim from different countries
who are fighting and who're talking
about Jihad what is the concept of
jihad as far as the word Jihad is
concerned Jihad comes from the Arabic
word jada which means to strive it means
to
struggle so Jihad basically means to
strive against struggle Jihad does not
mean holy
war holy war if you translate to Arabic
means there's no Arabic word in the
Quran or any of the this is a
mistranslation by the media and the
orientalist there's no holy war Jad does
not mean holy war Jad means to strive to
struggle furthermore
in Islamic context it means to strive
and struggle to improve the humanity it
means to strive and struggle to bring
peace in humanity it also means to
strive and struggle in the battlefield
in self-defense it also means to strive
and struggle against oppression Jad
basically means to drive and struggle
now coming to your question that how
come then so many youngsters from
different
countries they are fighting Point number
one there are possibilities and it's the
fact that some of the Muslims they are
being
misled by the antisocial
element that fight it's then in Islam
Etc misquoting out of context but this
is a small percentage the major reason
according to me is how the media
portrays like in India we very often
read in the
newspapers that the Muslim terrorist in
Kashmir killing so many people
headlines regularly you
read I was called to Kashmir the first
time in
2003 and I was thinking should I go or
not should I go or not so much of chaos
first
time in Kashmir the government gave
permission after 14 years to hold a
public lecture and the Gathering was
somewhat big 100,000 people in polo
grounds in the city of shagar
and when I went there there were guards
you know with guns and all around me and
I was expecting but there wasn't much
problem next day I went to Assam I
landed on the airport there were four
guards with guns machine gun what is
this there is killing killing Assam
takes place and there if I did not have
the guards I wouldn't be here to give
the talk but in the paper where do we
hear about the killing going on in
Assam there are more people being killed
in Assam than in Kashmir who hears about
the LT you know the LT the tamilans they
are called as Tamil Tigers they're not
called as Hindu terrorist why if Kashmir
Muslims do it they called as Muslim
terrorist if the Hindus and asslam do it
it's a local problem if the LTD does it
local problem in India you ask anyone
who has the knowledge of Law and Order
he will tell you the maximum killing is
done by the maist how many times do we
read in the newspaper we read in the
newspaper in news brief okay so many
people killed asslam news briefs Muslims
do it
headlines why there are black Shi in
every Community then one person came and
told me you know you should understand
this is a problem of
land Assam is not a problem of land it
is the Kashmir which is a problem of
land both the countries are fighting and
the poor Kashmir are being they are
being harassed neither here neither
there
if you go to Afghanistan that's a
problem of land the Americans have come
there and you call them terrorist see
what's happening in Palestine the
Jews the Jews were kicked out by Hitler
kicked out from
Germany the Palestinians the Arab
cousins they said Alan you're most
welcome in a house now imagine suppose a
traveler is homeless without a roof you
allow him to come to your house after a
few days he kicks you out and at the
doorstep you saying he has taken my
house give my house back they call
terrorist what
terrorist so you realize this is the
media it is
Media what we realize what's happening
in
Bosnia the Muslims correct I do agree
with you the Muslim that coming to the
picture but they are being harassed
where is
Humanity what have we done for the
people of Palestine for the people of
Iraq weapons of mass destruction I'm not
in favor of s
I don't consider a good Muslim but there
were problem when Saddam was ruling
after the Americans came the problem
they
multiplied correct so what talk about
weapons of mass destruction so what we
realize brother it is the media the
Muslims are being harassed they are the
sufferers and you call them terrorist so
that's the reason but there are black
Shi in the community also but the black
Shi are a
minority it's a minority the major thing
is the media you know Ira Irish Army in
UK it is a fight between the Catholics
and the Protestants no one calls them as
Catholic terrorist why more than 100
years but Tony BL the new prime minister
are more worried about Muslim terrorist
they AR worried about which has killed
hundreds of people how many Bomb Blast
have they done they are more having
secret meetings about how to
stop how to stop Muslim terrorist and
it's very common any politician he wants
the V bank the new prime minister came
then there Gasco bombing you know sail
Ahmed have you heard sail Ahmed very
good I have heard him I haven't seen him
it came in the Indian papers you know
sail Ahmed sail Ahmed was a fan of Dr
zakin and he organized Dr zakin lecture
in Bangalore in the full article on
terrorism then they talk about sail
Ahmed then they talk about Dr Z
why Dr Z is popular article will carry
more weight then they continue saying
that Dr zakin however is vehemently
against
terrorism they include my name in the
article you know the the issue of L
Majid in
Pakistan CDs were found of Dr zakin
n so you should be happy when the Indian
press is saying Dr zakin Nik is against
terrorism you should be happy that sail
has my DVDs you should be happy that L
mid has my DVDs if I'm against terrorism
so you should realize that maybe there
were tens of thousands of Muslims who
are done terrorist act because they are
my fans they stopped doing terrorism
because if a person is sick he has to go
to a doctor correct so you can't say
that sick people are going to the
hospital a sick person should go to the
hospital so if you assume that these are
terrorist organization and they're
hearing my lectures the Indian
government should be happy when Dr zik
speaks against terrorism they should be
happy that these people are listening to
me I may not be able to convince
everyone but at least quite a few I'm
convincing but in the article they write
my name for
vitage you know so it become if you
write against Islam the chances article
will be selected very easy and that's
common same with kushan Singh you know
kushman Singh now he age of 944 year
before last wrote article against me
couple of weeks back in November he
wrote article against me he says in the
first article he mentioned that I watch
Dr zakin nik's program religiously every
day he
writes he Praises me talks about my
memory and then criticizes me in his
style again he wrote an article that in
Delhi there was a book exhibition and
the hot seller was Dr zakin nik's book
on answers to the 20 common questions
asked by
non-muslims oh that person has fantastic
memory blah blah blah blah
but I will reply to four of his
questions and
replies to poke to alcohol to
polygamy as well as par
hijab and you read the
article time will not permit to speak
about everything in po I say that is the
most Shameless animal more than 70
diseases it's the only animal that
invites his friends to have sex with the
maid so I said if you eat pig you behave
like
Pig it the only animal that invites its
friends to have sex with the maid he
said I did not know that and he says
that I don't know the Western Country
they're having Pig and I don't see any
epidemic
disease see doctors tell us today that
don't go to a prostitute you have AIDS
but everyone that goes to prostitute
does not get AIDS the percentage is
small the minority of the people get
similarly everyone that has spoke
doesn't get these diseases but today
more than 50% of the Americans they are
suffering from hypertension and one of
the cause is because of pig eating
he talks about alcoholism Dr Zak Nik
says because of alcohol you so many
diseases he says Quran is not against
alcohol it's against getting intoxicated
now he's trying to interpret the Quran
this is the media and he says I'm of the
age of 94 years
old I'm drinking every day in my life
I've never got intoxicated I've never
got sick and I've never hurt any
individual now all these three things
age of 94 has never got intoxicated I
know so many comment friends who tell me
that they have seen him intoxicated so
many times never seen a
doctor maybe he forgot age of 94 he has
never hurt anyone he has hurt
me so what we realize that when you
write articles against Islam against
people who are famous you
get good readership you get good
viewership sh so similarly you realize
that today that the image that we have
of Muslim that
terrorist some may be fighting for the
freedom of the country imagine if I tell
you that the British government said
bhat Singh was a terrorist was bhat
Singh a
terrorist was he or not yes sir was bhat
Singh a terrorist or not his act was
like terrorist but was he a terrorist
according to you according to me also he
was not a
terrorist but just because the British
government says that bhat Singh is a
terrorist that doesn't mean I have to
agree with the government what we have
to realize this is Major the ploy of the
media that the reason the talk was based
on that so that we can sprad peace hope
to answer the question thank you
sir yes
brother pranam Guru my name is AD vas
kak I am from n hospital I am a medical
student my question is we are actually
very fortunate to get this human form of
life this is very very rare which comes
from millions and millions years so in
what respect we should utilize that
human form of life or what is
the most Sublime aim in our life or what
is the real goal of human form of life
the brother said that he a medical
friend from n hospital I like to mention
that I passed from n Hospital same
hospital I passed from the same Medical
College n hospital I passed in
1991 approximately 16 years back the
brother has a question that we get this
human
life how should we utilize this human
life Allah says in the Quran in chapter
number 51 verse number
56 that we have created the men and the
Jin not but to worship Him worship Him
means obeying him so best we can do with
this human life is to obey the
Commandments of almighty God and let
peace Prevail in this world and the
Hereafter the cre of the human beings he
will be the best person to give the
answer it's mentioned in Surah M chapter
number 67 verse number
two it's Allah who has created death and
life to test which of you good deeds
this life that we have brother is a test
for the
Hereafter we undergoing a test and if we
follow the Commandments of our creator
and Lead life according to what he has
said and let peace Prevail by sub
committing our will to the Creator will
be successful in this world as well as
the Hereafter hope they answer the
question yes but uh what we should we
young student what should you do for
that ah what you should
do brother should read the
Quran read the Quran and Implement on
the guidance of the Quran if you read
the Veda the Veda speaks about one God
no idol worship the V says there is a
Rishi to come there's a to come he will
show you good things that K is Prophet
Muhammad sahi wasallam this Quran is the
last and final revelation of almighty
God to the last and final messenger
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him read
this message accept it so that there is
peace in this world as well as in hope
the answer the question brother thank
you very much sir yes sister uh myself
arti I'm a
non-muslim I'd like to ask a question
that uh first of all very thanks for uh
your and giving me this opportunity to
listen to you and understand M
Islam uh what I understood from your
talk is mainly that it's a religion
which believes in peace and Harmony and
uh scientific and rational
beliefs if it is so then how does it
believe in the whole idea of God and how
does it believe the whole idea of heaven
or the hell if it's so
rational has a question that heard the
leure she's very happy to know Islam is
a religion of peace and it's a
scientific religion it's a rational
religion you're asking that if Islam is
a rational religion then how come it
believes in God it believes in Heaven
and Hell sister the only way you can
believe in God is through science today
if I have to prove to an atheist the
only way I can prove is through the
Quran with the help of science the best
tool I've got today previously it was
Miracles then came the age of literature
and poetry every age Quran is a Miracle
of Miracles it's a miracle of all times
so because of this if you heard my talk
I've proved that because a person who
believes in science if he's rational he
will have to agree that Quran is the
word of God if he does not believe in
science if he's not rational if he's not
understanding there High chances he will
not believe in the Quran that's the
reason I said today science is not
eliminating God it is eliminating models
of God as far as science is concerned
the concept of God most of the scientist
they believe in the existence of God
today previously according to Francis
bin it says that little knowledge of
science makes you an atheist but indepth
knowledge of science makes you a
believer in God now coming to a second
question about heaven and hell now if we
analyze the Quran
whatever the Quran speaks about science
approximately you can say that 80% what
the Quran speaks about science has been
proved to be 100% correct about the
creation of the universe about the shape
of the Earth Light of the Moon that the
sun rotates and revolves water cycle
geology botony Etc 80% of what the Quran
speaks about science is 100% proved to
be correct the remaining 20% it goes in
the ambiguous slot neither right neither
wrong so my logic says when 80% is 100%
correct and the remaining 20% is neither
right neither wrong not even. 1% of the
20% has been proved to be wrong my logic
says that inshallah God willing even
that 20% will be right so Heaven and
Hell Angels Jin science hasn't advance
that far today science has advanced
maybe to understand it % of the quranic
verses we speak about science
tomorrow maybe 50 years later 100 years
later 200 years later science will talk
about heaven we'll talk about hell we'll
talk about Jin so my logic says it's not
an illogical belief it's a logical
believe when 80% is 100% correct and the
remaining 20% not even. 1% is wrong no
scientist today can say that he can
prove scientifically there is no hell no
scientist today can prove scientifically
there's no Heaven he can say I don't
know maybe it is maybe it is not it is
ambiguous so my logic says when 20% is
ambiguous neither right neither wrong
when 80% 100% correct I being a
scientific person I being a rational
person I say that inshallah God willing
even that 20% will be correct that the
reason I believe in hell I believe in
heaven and also believe in the angels
and the Gin hope to answer the question
um I I still have some clarification I
need some clarification anything
connected with the same question yes
yeah actually you said that science also
follows or believes in God or also Islam
do that then what is the exact
explanation that is that it has given
for God or for heaven or hell sister did
you hear my full talk yeah did you hear
my talk which I gave earlier last week
is the Quran God's word no sir this is
my first talk so in this talk I spent 15
minutes trying to repeat in a nutshell
what I spoken to us what I request you
you take my video CET recording is the
Quran God's word and I've proved there
that Quran is God's word and also proved
to an atheist the existence of almighty
God which I did today in a but in a fast
way so I have proved that God has to
exist if God did not exist who wrote
this Quran who wrote this Quran 1400
years ago talking about my question is
also then who wrote this Quran who wrote
it the Creator wrote
it God wrote it no human being can write
sorry what is the explanation for that
the explanation is my talk of to our
sister you can take the video cassette
and the similar talk I had given in
Bombay
1995 I IID request some of the
volunteers the lady volunteer to give
you a copy of my talk which I said in
1995 in bah matushri take that talk
inshallah it will give you more details
about the explanation of God as well as
the existence of God and Quran is the
word of God hope that answer the
question sister you can collect the book
also Quran and modern s on the way out
as well as is the Quran God's word these
should satisfy most of your answers on
that topic yes brother thank you sir sir
I'm Dr Rajesh I am homeopathic doctor
and uh I have two questions that uh I
have read that about Muhammad pagar as
the last and the final Prophet why the
stress is given on the word last and the
final and are you afraid of any new one
and if God sides and we'll send a new
one don't you welcome him
and thank you sir brother asked two
questions one thing that why do you
stress so much that he's the last
prophet if God wants to send a second
one can't he send and the last question
is if I want to see almighty God what is
the solution I'll come to the last
question later on the first question why
do I stress that Prophet Muhammad is the
last prophet not only I stress
the vi stress the puran stress the Bible
stress as well as the Quran and the
other scriptures Allah says in the
Quran in chapter number 33 verse number
40 that Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him is not the father of any of you but
he is the prophet of almighty God he is
the Seal of the
prophets and Allah is all knowing full
of knowledge now when almighty God said
if almighty God wants to send he can
surely send but almighty God does not
speak a lie almighty God doesn't tell a
lie it's mentioned in the Quran in
chapter 33 Surah aab 33:40 that this is
the last prophet so almighty God knows
if he wanted to send as the prophet he
would not have mentioned this as the
last prophet so because he had mentioned
the last prophet I believe in it and
since almighty God he knows the future
you and I don't know the future almighty
God knows the future and he said that
this is the last therefore I believe in
it now depending upon the requirement
what was required he has given some
people say why didn't he send Prophet
Muhammad in the day
one you know my son wants to do
medicine he said why don't you put me in
Medical College directly first you have
to go to school standard one standard
two standard three pass school then
medical right so depending upon how the
humanity progressed almighty God kept on
sending
Messengers and by name forah mentioned
but there were many Revelations s Torah
zabur injil by name is mentioned now
almighty God thought it fit that 1400
years back Humanity reached a level to
understand the Quran then he sent his
last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him last and
final message the Glorious Quran now if
almighty God wants he can surely s but
since he has mentioned he will not s he
will not sin and and this religion has
completed the previous scriptures were
not in the complete form Allah mentions
almighty god mentioned in the Quran in
Surah ma chapter 5 verse number three
that on this day have I completed my
favor unto you have chosen for you Islam
and complete the religion for you after
the religion of Islam is completed
nothing new can be added nothing can be
subtracted from this religion it's
complete that's the reason if anyone
today says that he gets Revelation from
almighty God anyone who says he the
prophet of God he has to go to a
psychiatrist today there are hundreds of
people claiming to be God people
claiming to be prophets of
God they require psychiatrist because
after this no other revelation will come
after this no other Prophet will come
regarding the second part of the
question what can you
do if you want to see God anyone if you
tell what what should I do I'll tell you
what should do in this world
you cannot see God that was Moses peace
be upon him it's mentioned in the Quran
he wanted to see God so almighty God
said look at the mountain I will show a
glimpse of me to the mountain so what
happened to the mountain by looking what
happened to the mountain Prophet Moses
fainted so in this world you cannot see
but you can see in the next World if you
go to Jenna you will have everything
food everything you'll have the people
it mentioned thei they will crave to see
the face of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
so if
you want to see almighty God you have to
read the final revelation of God the
Glorious Quran and follow the final
Revelation and follow the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him if you follow the
scripture and the last and final
Revelation inshallah you'll go to Jenna
if I follow I will go to Jenna and then
inshallah if we both have the same name
both of us will go to Jenna and
inshallah we will see almighty God hope
to answer the question thank you sir
yes
brother India
ch
brother has a question that like people
are fighting in Kashmir and they're
doing Jihad similarly in Manipur the
people are fighting and he had to leave
the city and come here and because of
the terrorist he's 15 days here he's
happy to learn about Islam he wants to
know that why isn't peace channel in
Manipur yeah and he wants to know that
why do Muslims keep up here there are
two basic questions brother in Kashmir
as I mentioned I can't say everyone is
doing J they struggling they're striving
wait wait wait sir you are thinking me
as a wrong I say you you are the right I
perfectly understood a question brother
okay I never said that you are wrong and
your question is also very good brother
but I'm trying to clarify that everyone
fighting in Kashmir they may not be
doing the true jiad some people for the
alterior motive may be doing wrong thing
those who are truly following the
Commandment of the Quran and fighting
then you can say that they are doing Jad
I cannot put a blanket rule that
everyone in Kashmir is doing Jihad
J now coming to your question of Manipur
I know that there's a lot of fighting
going in Manipur and because of them you
are here maybe it is Allah's planning
almighty God has
planned that because of the fighting
your here leave us at peace in this
world maybe you'll get peace in the the
Hereafter also correct now you have
heard such a good lecture about peace
this world peace is a temporary peace We
should strive but the best piece is the
peace in the
Hereafter now coming to your question
why do Muslims keep up beard and why
peace channel is not seen in Manipur as
far as the peace Channel not seen in
Manipur you can easily take the
frequency if you put a dish maybe the
cable operators may not be putting it
but if you put a dish which cost just a
few thousand rupees and face it in the
direction of 68° East towards inight 10
inshallah you get the peace Channel you
can try and tell the cable operator to
see it we cannot go to Manipur and try
and force them but if they put the dish
and face it to 68° East and tune into to
the frequency inshah I'll get it coming
to your question why do Muslims keep a
beard what I say that if the label shows
you intent to wear it i' given the talk
that if the label shows your intent we
it for
example if you go to a
conference of intellectuals the people
wear a label I'm a doctor I'm an
engineer I'm a scientist it gives an
informal
introduction when you go to a gathering
or conference only of doctors then the
speciality is mentioned says Dr so and
so he a cardiologist neurologist
nephologist if you have a heart problem
you go to cardiologist if you want to
know about kidney then nephologist if
you have brain problem neurologist
informal
introduction the Quran says in Surah
Anam chapter number 6 verse number
54 the Quran says
that that when you meet those who
believe in our signs you sayam alaykum
you wish them Salam alayum Islam pay
stress on saying assalamu alaykum it's
the religion of
peace now minimum in a day every Muslim
at least has to pray five times a day
now when he prays five times a day even
if he prays only the F Salah the compar
Salah five times into two when we end
the Salah we
sayum may peace and mercy and the
blessings of Allah be on all the people
on my right May the peace and mercy and
blessings of almighty God be all the
people on my left every Salah I say
twice I have to read minimum five Salah
minimum 10 times I'm wishing Salam to
all the people on my right the peace
Beyond people on the left if I read
the that is another 10 times so minimum
times I wish
Salam to the people on my right and
people on my left if I read the normal
Sunnah it may be more anytime I meet a
Muslim I have to wish him assalam
alaykum may peace be on you it's also
mentioned in the Quran Ina chapter
number four verse number 86 it says when
anyone gives you a greeting gives you a
courteous greeting wish back more
courteously or at least the same so
anyone wishes me assalam alaykum I have
to
sayum if anyone says peace be on you I
have to say may peace and mercy be on
you if someone says alayum I have to
sayam
I have to wish back better if someone
says I have to wish back at least the
same if someone tell meum and if I
say words are the same but it's coming
from the bottom of the heart even that
is better so Allah says in the Quran
wish back more courteously now when I'm
traveling and when I meet Muslims How
will I know that he's a Muslim
so we have identity beard but today in
the media if you are a beard you a
terrorist
yeah now but uh look at this brother let
me please let me complete the answer if
the SS keep a beard and wear a turban
they are called a stch followers if
Muslims keep a beard they called a
terrorist if the Christian nuns they
cover their head they're called as
religious if Muslim women are covered
they call a subjugated media media media
see this beard this beard can't even H
afly and this cap of mine it can't even
h a fly if you read the Quran the Quran
does not say you should keep a beard
there's only one verse in the Quran in
Surah T chapter number 20 verse number
94 where Moses peace be upon him he
catches the beard of Haron Alam Aon
peace be on him and he says that oh son
of my mother why do you catch me by my
beard that is the only place where the
beard has come but our beloved Prophet
says in say bukari Vol number
seven Hadith number 78 and 781 our
beloved Prophet said do the opposite of
what the pagans
do trim your mustaches
short and grow the beard now because it
a commandment of the Prophet Allah says
in the
Quran obey Allah and obey the messenger
a prophet has commanded and we
obey and it is a good way for me to
identify many people when I go to
anywhere on the streets or go to a
foreign country they see a captain of
beard asalam Alum asalam Alum waum Salam
it's an informal introduction I'm
spreading
peace so what we realize that it is an
informal introduction and like for
example if you go in a car if you're a
doctor he puts a cross why you identify
that that car belongs to a doctor if you
have some emergency you can stop the car
and you can ask for help now when you
see a person having a beard as well as
covering the head you know he's a Muslim
I remember and if you ask your
grandparents you ask your grandparents
50 years back 100 years back they will
tell you that the non-muslims when they
wanted to hire a taxi a capab they
looked for a driver who wore a cap and
we had a beard Muslim driver he w't take
me for a ride when they wanted to buy
from a grocery they wanted to buy from a
person whose owner had a beard Muslim he
will not cheat but today if you are a
cap or a
beard it means you're a terrorist so if
the name is maligned we have to
reinstate That Glory to this
beard fine and it is only a label it's a
commandment of the prophet he said it
therefore we do it it cannot even h a
fly but it gives an informal
introduction that we Muslims we can wish
each other and if you have any problem
if you require help it's the duty of
Muslim to help the neighbor you stop a
man with a beard and a cap inshallah
he'll help you hope the answer the
question thank
you thank you brother can we have the
next question
sister Salam alikum Dr nyak my name is
Monita I'm a media professional I wanted
to know if accepting Prasad is Haram for
a Muslim and
why sister the question that is
accepting Prasad for a Muslim Haram or
not Prasad is the food that is given to
God to the idols that set in
Hinduism Quran says in no less than four
different places in Surah Bak chapter
number 2 verse number 173 in Sur ma
chapter number 5 verse number three in
Surah Anam chapter number 6 verse number
145 and surel chapter number 16 verse 15
it says
that for you for food dead meat blood
the Flesh of swine and any food on which
any name besides Almighty God's name is
taken so any food on which any name
besides Almighty God's name is taken it
is called as Haram that's the reason to
accept prad and to eat Prasad is
prohibited in Islam and even if you read
the vas even in the vas since the Veda
clearly
mentions of that God there is no pratima
there is no image there is no Idol there
is no sculpture there is no photograph
there is no painting even giving food to
the idol is prohibited in the Veda so
that's the reason because it's prohib in
the Veda it is wrong to put food on the
idols similarly because the Quran
prohibits it for us Muslims to accept it
or to eat it is wrong sister hope that
answerers the question uh sir one more
thing I'm a Cindi and I go to the
gurudwara there is no Idol at the
gurudwara there's just a grun we still
have Prasad in the gurara it's called
Kaa Prasad but you still can't accept
that what is the reason for that sister
that's it's not accepted it's not
offered to an idol that's right sister
I'm a student of even the gurug
gr and even according to the sik
scriptures the gr gurug Gran it speaks
about Oneness of God and it says that
almighty God has got no Idols no images
there are various attributes given to
almighty God rahee Kim Allah various
till here we are going together but
unfortunately when you go to
gurudwara though sism does not believe
in the concept of God in which there are
images but yet they worship the grun as
a guru because the Gus have gone and on
this when they give the food it's
indirectly
similar though according to the
scriptures idol worship is prohibited so
because of this
indirect giving of the food even
according to the guru Gran almighty God
does not require to eat so where is the
question of you giving food to almighty
God Quran says in Surah Anam chapter 6
verse number 14 Allah Feth everyone but
does not require to be fed so where's
the question of you giving food to
almighty God so sister you are not
following the adig gr now because you're
not following the adig grant almighty
God does not require food he can sustain
without the food he is the one who feeds
everyone hope that answer the
question I would request the brothers to
be seated for two minutes as we close I
would request our honored speakers who
have come from USA Canada to kindly come
on stage the brothers would like to have
a glimpse and we have this Grand
successful we request brother Yasir faga
shik jafer Idris kindly come on stage
with Dr Zakir NY let our audience have a
view of our wonderful speakers who have
come all the way thousands of mil they
have come here to share their views many
of our audience was not here on the
other days we'd like them to have an
idea we request the audience to kindly
be seated for 2 minutes as we finish the
closing ceremony and I request brother
Dr Bilal Phillips brother Yasir faga Dr
Jaffer Idris from Sudan
dran sidiki arari from Saudi Arabia Kar
sherzad and Dr MDU Muhammad to kindly
come on stage brothers and sisters
kindly give them a good fairwell from
Mumbai
Allah for being with
us Captain Asam memory also from Saudi
Arabia they have been giving talks for
all the last 10 days we had six sessions
every
day and it was a wonderful time having
them we all have the audience as well as
the speakers have I'm sure appreciated
enjoyed the session and on a whole the
conference focus of creating a better
awareness and understanding of Islam and
its message of peace and help remove
misconceptions about Islam has been
served mashallah
love I would request Dr Zakir just thank
them in a half a minute on the
microphone our wonderful speakers who
have come all the way from USA UK and
other countries some of our speakers of
course have already left brother Anwar
ibraim Abdul Rahim Green from UK Sal
alamri from UAE Dr Ahmed saudin and
others and of course the former Imam of
the Majid Ali Madina and others have
already left those who are here are
present here Dr Zakir to give his final
words firstly i' like to thank Allah
subhana wa ta'ala for making this 10day
Islamic International Conference to be a
grand success and it's only because of
Allah's help that this was possible and
secondly I'd like to thank our learned
Scholars and speakers M have come from
different parts of the world from
different countries from USA from UK
from Saudi Arabia from UAE from Malaysia
and very different countries without
them this event would not have been
possible and though they're very busy
mashallah most most of them stayed for
10 days and I thank them for the efforts
and
inshallah Allah will bless them and in
pray to Allah to grant them jna and last
but not the least I would like to thank
all the audiences there brother W also
from USA from
Texas from Texas USA we have other
speakers some in the TV studios and I'd
like to thank the people of Bombay and
the people of India who have come from
different parts of Bombay
to give us a patient hearing and to
accept the message of Peace thank you
ald yes brother Dr Bilal Philip would
like to have a
word I just like to thank you all on
behalf of all of the speakers who have
come uh we have been welcomed here in in
Bombay in India we've had a very good
time here and we thank you all for your
uh support and uh benefit fit your
useful questions and we ask Allah to
bless you all to guide those of you who
haven't found their way to Islam as yet
and we ask Allah to bring peace to this
land and to the world through
Islam Brothers we request our audience
to kindly as the speakers moved down
give them a with a Allah abbar as they
move into The Pavilions and may I
Captain Al sh an ex pilot with the Air
Force and also with the Saudi Arabian
Airlines yes I would like just to say
one word to the brothers may Allah
reward them all beginning of Dr Dak Nike
and the unknown soldiers the people who
behind the screen who have done a lot of
good effort and duties all these 10 days
may Allah reward you if we don't know
you Allah knows you Allah will reward
you inshallah tala we thank you
all one
word
peace Alum y thank you Brothers we thank
Allah subhana tala for making this
program possible and we request you
lastly i' would like to personally thank
that as many aw that we have got more
than 2,000 volunteers 1,000 from Bombay
1,000 from different cities of India and
they stayed here for about 12 to 15 days
that come a couple of days earlier this
event would not have been possible if it
was not for the effort so we thank them
also and may Allah subhana tala give
them Ma as well as all the other
technical staff and the staff of the
organization we thank you all as well as
the supporters